bon je vais pas faire durer le suspense
plus longtemps le mil axe iii est un
smartphone qui est fait avant tout pour
le
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nouveau colis nouveaux colis
quoi ils nous font décoller difficile
owen vaches vaches à regarder nouveau
smartphone de caterpillar
le s 61 donc ce qu'on va faire d'ici
quelques jours c'est qu'on va le tester
on va regarder un peu ce qu'on peut
faire avec et notamment une caméra
thermique
donc franchement il ya vraiment des
applications super sympa à voir là
dessus bon aujourd'hui on a le choix va
pouvoir tester plusieurs produits
on va choisir ensemble bon celui-là il
vient d'arriver on va cesser le temps de
l'ouvrir de tester tranquillement donc
je le ferais un peu plus tard on va donc
choisir aujourd'hui ce qu'on va tester
qu'est ce qu'on en smartphones deux
côtés on a celui là le jelly des
smartphones et plus petits qui existent
n'ont pas forcément aujourd'hui on à
leurs ennemis
un autre six pros on peut se tenter ça
on peut se tenter aussi le wild corona
le vieux 2 go on a les yeux de plus ça
on a de l'audio ci tient pas forcément
aujourd'hui mais dans quelques jours on
a le wimax 3 2 chimiquiers là on or plus
on a déjà fait ce que c'est bon ça c'est
bon ça c'est alors ça c'est pour la
sécurité du studio faut que j'installe
très très rapidement et tout le matos
cas là on à leurs lots mis d'eux a testé
on nasa a testé aussi vraiment je m'en
occupe c'est le z2 pro du midi j à huy
tiens on a ça qu'on n'a toujours pas
fait aussi l'amazonie co va falloir
qu'on s'en occupe de sortie très très
rapidement tous trouvent ça sera toi
allez toi on va commencer par lui
aujourd'hui il ya aussi plein d'autres
produits qui vont arriver d'ici quelques
jours
il ya aussi des ordis de dell là là là
juste là de xps un oled en lcd donc ça
on va le tester dans quelques jours
tranquillement le temps que des primes
guen en main donc dites moi ce que vous
voulez qu'on teste dans les jours qui
viennent
comme ça au moins je me ferais une idée
puis on pourra avancer plus rapidement
voilà pour vous faire plaisir donc
aujourd'hui on va ce check et le mx3 bon
je vais pas faire durer le suspense plus
longtemps le mil axe iii est un
smartphone qui est fait avant tout pour
le multimédia
ça au moins ça a le mérite d'être clair
tout simplement parce que vous avez un
énorme écran au dessus de quasiment 7
pouces si vous voulez tout savoir voilà
vous avez mes notes
je vous laisse lire là donc la mi-match
3 le prix les infos voilà si maintenant
les hiéroglyphes s'est pas trop fait
pour vous on a carrément en parler
directement comme ça ça sera beaucoup
plus faible alors le mx3 je vous dis il
ya vraiment super intérêt c'est son
écran c'est pas le smartphone le plus
puissant du marché
on n'a pas un soft complètement dingue
on a un instinct dragonne 136 octo cores
cadencés jusqu'à 1,8 gigahertz
bon je vais vous passez le côté un peu
technique parce que c'est hyper est
dramatique mais qu'il faut retenir c'est
que c'est pas une bête de compet c'est
pas le smartphone qui va être le plus
rapide le plus performant par contre il
a un vrai vrai intérêt vous trouverez
entre 259 et 299 euros mais surtout il a
un écran de 6,9 pouces avec une
résolution de 2560 par 1600 pixels ratio
18/9 c'est une dali psc du lcd mais par
contre ça marche extrêmement bien et
c'est tout l'intérêt de ce produit il
est complètement légal pour regarder des
vidéos sur youtube
vous pouvez bien évidemment venir up les
ou mais là c'est vraiment vraiment
agréable et séance à cet écran de
quasiment 7 pouces est à dire 6,9 pouces
est tout simplement génial en plus de ça
ce grand écran est super pour profiter
d'un stade g et sapant du multimédia
croyez moi c'est tout simplement génial
ce qui est vraiment super là dessus
aussi c'est l'expérience gaming parce
que en ayant grand écran de quasiment 7
pouces vous allez vraiment pouvoir
profiter de l'expérience complètement
immersive ça c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment génial alors comme je vous le
dis vous avez pas énormément de
puissance là dessus donc vous attendez
pas à faire tourner des jeux
complètement fou paye bg vous pouvez y
arriver par moments il a qu'un petit peu
c'est un petit peu le point un peu
négatif
j'irais là dessus par contre pour plein
d'autres je vous aurais absolument aucun
problème et vous allez vraiment pour
vous faire plaisir
diddy multimédia dit audio là dessus
vous avez des hauts parleurs stéréo
alors c'est bien et pas bien je vous
laisse juger par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors haut parleurs stéréo c'est un
appareil qu'on nous vend pont du
multimédia donc ils ont forcément mis
des haut parleurs stéréo
on se dit cool l'expérience est bien
alors l'expérience et bien on va pas se
mentir l'expérience et bien par contre
pour mon d'une expérience de haut
parleur mono là dessus je vous explique
pas ce que vous avez ici en haut
parleurs qui situent juste ici vous avez
deuxième haut parleurs qui est l'afp on
retrouve un peu classiquement sur les
smartphones qui ont des hauts parleurs
stéréo sauf que là vous avez un son qui
est plus médium aigu et là le spectre
est un peu plus large
donc pour moi là dessus vous êtes
vraiment la qualité d'un haut parleur
mono celui ci via un peu en renfort
n'est fondamentalement l'enfant pas je
vous fait écouter vous allez voir je le
bush
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est le son du deuxième haut
parleurs pas terrible loth c'est ça
ce qui fait que lorsque je vais boucher
celui là que j'utilise pas brouiller
vraiment que là vous avez un tout petit
renfort mais ça fait pas vraiment la
différence
donc il faut vraiment considérer que ce
smartphone un haut parleur mono un léger
renfort à gauche mais pas plus petite
expérience multimédia a dit audio dit
aussi odieux au casf on a ici une prise
jack
on va voir ce que ça dit et on va
regarder si au final l'expérience audio
là dessus à la prise jack est
intéressante oui ou non si ça te fait si
ça le fait pas ça marche très bien
le son est assez médium mais malgré tout
dans cette gamme de tarifs ça marche
très bien alors la qualité est là
rassurez vous ça pas vous arracher les
oreilles je trouve que ça marche il ya
un beau volume sonore
l'expérience est cool donc pour moi en
termes de multimédia que ce soit sur le
visionnage que ce soit au casque c'est
vraiment bien maintenant qu'on va les
faire c'est qu'on va aller en extérieur
voir ce que donne cet écran dès lors
vous avez beaucoup de lumière est ce qu
on y va quand même quelque chose oui ou
non
alors là pour moi un extérieur ça marche
très très bien j'ai poussé la luminosité
up l'aja pouces carrément à fond j'y
vois vraiment bien alors je sais pas si
on se rend vraiment compte comme ça
lorsque vous le regardez vous mais pour
moi la luminosité est cool je remets une
vidéo est pour moi la qualité largement
suis certain on se rend moins compte
avec caméra de ce que je peux voir moi
en réalité mais la qualité vraiment là
c'est vraiment très très bien et même si
je mens en plein soleil
le rendu est vraiment agréable donc ce
smartphone est complètement optimisé
pour la partie multimédia
néanmoins il ya un temps qui est très
intéressant c'est la partie photo vidéo
ce que je propose c'est de la tester ce
faire quelques photos quelques vidéos et
puis après on va débriefer on va voir si
c'est intéressant oui ou non alors en
terme de vidéo on a un rendu qui est
quand même plutôt pas mal sur la caméra
arrière on a de quoi faire un terme
d'optique ça marche sache c'est pas non
plus le truc le plus où ce qui existe
sur le marché
par contre ça c'est franchement bien la
faire dès lors vous avez beaucoup de
lumière comme là aujourd'hui on en plein
mois d'octobre malgré tout ils font un
temps assez incroyable on est quoi on
est quelque chose comme le 18 octobre
assez hallucinant à ces allusions ou
plutôt cool donc la caméra arrière
marche plutôt bien
quand vous avez beaucoup lumière
maintenant on va se tuer sans les
caméras avant que c'est pas mal même en
termes de stabilisation
ça fonctionne bien alors surtout si vous
me connaissez si vous habitude avec moi
décapage stabilisation ça pardonne pas
et là je trouve que pour le coup le
rendu plutôt pas mal en termes de photos
vidéos il fonctionne plutôt pas mal faut
dire que j'ai oublié quand même plutôt
bon là dessus vous avez à l'arrière tout
de suite alors vous regardez un capteur
12 mégapixels + 5 mégapixels le 12
mégapixels dans le capteur principal de
5 mégapixels vient pour la profondeur de
champ relance je lui reproche un petit
peu sur un mode portrait il a du mal à
venir à détourer venir vraiment repérer
les contours j'ai honoré qui est un
petit peu flou ça peut pas non plus
réellement lui en vouloir on est sur un
processeur qui pas non plus extrêmes
mandingue là dessus on est sur un timbre
agon 636 si on voulait vraiment avoir un
truc de dingue on irait plutôt sur 1 845
pour venir travailler des tourelles de
la puissance et de la performance
derrière ça ferait beaucoup mieux
néanmoins je trouve que là dessus le
boulot quand même plutôt bien fait ça
marche plutôt bien
à savoir qu'il ya une ouverture de f 1.9
donc assez lumineux en plus pro photo
vous avez un autofocus dual pixels ce
qui marche plutôt bien
bon là en passant les caméramans vous
avez une caméra de celle fille 8
mégapixels une ouverture de f 2.0 du
pareil quand vous avez beaucoup lumière
ça marche extrêmement bien il faut les
nourrir ces petites bêtes avec de la
lumière si vous passez en faible
luminosité
ça sera un peu moi ça après pour un
smartphone qui coûte entre 269 et 299
euros
franchement le résultat est là et en
termes de photos vidéos je trouve ça
assez satisfaisant en termes de
performances il obtient la note de 118
1755 sûr en tout ce qu ils le placent
largement en deçà des 50 meilleurs par
contre vous le dis on est sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme ça fonctionne
c'est plutôt bien n'a rien à leur
reprocher là dessus en terme doit s y
tourner sur me why 10 avec un android
huit points qui tombe derrière ça va
très très bien ça fonctionne
l'autonomie est excellente avec une
batterie de 5500 millions paire eur avec
une coupe charge près ça marche plutôt
bien l'autonomie toujours un petit peu
compliqué à définir pour moi vous tenez
une journée dans la mesure où vous
bourinet pas vous êtes vous regarder et
ça ça fonctionne aussi très bien il a un
don en métal qui est assez séduisant
le capteur d'empreintes digitales
fonctionne très très très bien il se
recharge en usb type c est dans l'absolu
c'est plutôt satisfaits et aux
smartphones point que je pourrais mettre
aussi un petit peu entre parenthèses
mais c'est normal par
un smartphone qui quand même
relativement gros c'est le point il fait
2 121 g s'est pas non plus hallucinant
quand vous mettez dans la poche vous
savez qu'il est là c'est pas non plus un
des smartphones les plus lourds que j'ai
pu trouver sur le marché mais une fois
de plus avec un écran de 6,2 pouces
serait compliqué de faire plus léger et
s'il vous plaît les discours trois
couleurs en bleu en noir ou en or si
vous avez suivi l'histoire des roms de
chinoise des chiots me qui ne sont pas
disponibles ou qu'on pourrait pas avoir
au niveau rang global ne vous inquiétez
pas sur ce modèle là vous l'avez en
version globale dont vous pourrez la
voir en français sans aucun problème
s'il vous intéresse je vous ai mis un
lien en bas dans la description vous
pouvez l'acheter chez mon partenaire
dick mol qui me l'a prêté le smartphone
en tout cas je serais plutôt cool à la
question à qui est destiné ce smartphone
parce que ça c'est quand même beau plat
revient par là mon lapin c'est quand
même relativement important de savoir à
qui il est destiné
il est destiné pour moi aux personnes
qui cherchent du multimédia qui veulent
des grands écrans qui veulent des écrans
de quasiment 7 pouces et qui sont déçus
du fait de pas pouvoir trouver une
beaucoup de produits comme ça sur le
marché
donc ça vous pouvez y aller il est aussi
destiné aux personnes qui ont des
grandes minces qu'il est absolument pas
mon cas pour pouvoir effectivement le
tenir à une main pour pouvoir tu as fait
tous vos messages assez facilement alors
attention des smartphones de cette
taille ne sont pas faits pour être
utilisé à une seule main vous risquez
lorsque vous avez cherché des lettres un
peu plus lointaine de le faire tomber
je vous conseille vraiment de l'utiliser
à demain pour pouvoir
vraiment écrire ce que vous voulez hélas
comme ça vous êtes plutôt tranquille et
c'est même plutôt facile pour envoyer
vos messages
pour résumer je suis satisfait de ce
mina kz3 je trouve vraiment très bien au
niveau de l'écran pour le multimédia
c'est vraiment il perd agréable leçon
fonctionne bien mais partait plutôt sur
l'idée d'un haut-parleur mono car
parleurs stéréo au casque ça va très
bien pour des jeux des applications pas
trop gourmand pour faire tourner tout ce
que vous voulez dessus ça ira et surtout
il est un tarif qui est vraiment canon
entre 269 et 299 euros donc s'il vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce qu'un smartphone comme les mines axe
3 vous pourrez vous tenter et dites-moi
également si des smartphones avec des
grands écrans de quasiment 7 pouces
voire sept et plus si affinités pourrez
vous tentez vous marquez tout ça je vous
invite bien évidemment à rester
connectés comme je le dis il ya plein
plein plein plein d'autres produits à
tester donc ça c'est super cool on va se
faire plaisir des surprises de
nouveautés des exclus pas mal de choses
qui arrivent très rapidement je n'en dis
pas plus on va faire un test un peu en
avant première sur un smartphone mais
j'aime tes journées plussoyer ça je vous
embrasse et à très bientôt
tu y joues
[Musique]